this week as we continue to focus on the
best new books martin amos
he was already a legend in england
before he moved to america 10 years ago
over the past five decades both here and
abroad amos has written books that have
been thralled
provoked and chastised recently we met
amos here in new york city as he
promoted his latest book
a deeply personal meditation on love
and loss if a novel isn't giving you a
good time
in whatever way throw it across the room
over your shoulder don't waste your life
reading stuff that isn't giving you
pleasure
martin amos has never been at a loss for
words
in person or on the page he grew up the
son of one of england's
greatest writers kingsley amos and was
told by plenty he'd never measure up
an early attempt at screenwriting didn't
help the 1980 film
saturn 3 starring kirk douglas harvey
keitel and
farah fawcett playing three astronauts
stuck on a space station with a
homicidal robot
was widely panned let her go
conform but that interaction with
hollywood access helped lead to his
first breakout novel
money later adapted by the bbc building
it's john uh i think i might run out of
money
that's just too bad i'm afraid there
isn't any more what
just kidding slick zero problem i'll
send some ride over amos quickly joined
a brilliant group of other contemporary
writers
including ian mcewen and salman rushdie
rushdie was the one who spent the better
part of a decade in hiding after iran's
ayatollah
called for his death claiming rushdie's
novel the satanic verses was offensive
to islam
together all these writers kept turning
out bold
unpredictable fiction amos's latest
is called inside story is it possible to
say what this book is about
well in the end it's about death
but it's also a love letter to life yeah
but that that just um sharpens
the the strange difficulty
of dying i always thought the pressure
must come off and you must
you must weaken into death but in fact
it goes on being very hard to die
inside story is called a novel but is
more than anything a goodbye
to both family and friends like another
fellow author
saul bello and christopher hitchens his
best friend
who died in 2011. hitchens was one of
the 20th century's
great rockin tours his excesses both in
life
and on the page were well documented
amos has said hitchens is the only
person he could ever be completely
honest with
is there a way for you to quantify
who you miss the most whether it's
christopher whether it's
saul whether it's your dad i might too
much miss my dad
but it would have to be christopher
who's an exact and contemporary and
we worked in the same building in our
early twenties
we got married at the same time we got
divorced at the same time we got
remarried at the same time we had
additional children at the same time
you're going to get a few friends
who seem to keep pace with you but not
many in your life
they're your twin in some way for the
last four years amos has turned much of
his attention to the outgoing american
administration
and says he's soured completely on the
way democracy works
i was profoundly disappointed that trump
paid no moral price for his presidency
there was no rejection of trumpism
from it he lost the election i know
but he was competitive i'm an insane
optimist about america
and i thought that would be some
self-regulating
mechanism in the american electorate
that would
say we actually we don't like that kind
of government
but you can't tell people how to vote
you can and you can be shocked
by it but also like well that's
democracy yes yeah it is a system that
has endured
yeah amos's politics have never been
predictable
but his writing routine is now nearing
the end of his career
he's acutely aware of life's landmarks
and also that as a novelist
and human being documenting them and
understanding them
are not necessarily the same thing i
went to a
film with salman rushdie while he was
still under police
escort and so once we got in the cinema
which was full there was no getting out
of it
and the film was four weddings and a
funeral
and you know no iranian
torture could have put us through
anything worse than that and
on the street outside as i was sort of
wiping away my tears
and smoking cigarettes i said
why is it so popular that film and
salman said
the world has bad taste haven't you
noticed
yikes before you nail me martin wasn't
going after four weddings in a funeral
i have bad taste no offense um but yeah
never
as we said never at never to loss for
words and this uh this book really is um
very personal you can see how much
christopher's death and others have
weighed on him
as he evaluates his own life it was so
interesting to see him go
in on the election the way he did i
loved watching the two of you yeah he's
been outspoken for for years on it
yeah yeah good stuff jeff okay